[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه الحلقه
الجديده من مستقبل الطاقه هذه الملفاتنا
مع تسديد العقوبات الغربيه هل تنجح روسيا
في الالتفاف شرقا لتسويق انتاجها من النفط
والغاز
وقطاع الاسمنت المسؤول عن سبعه في المئه
من الانبعاثات الكربونيه ماذا تفعل دول
المنطقه لتحسين الامتثال البيئي في صناعته
[موسيقى]
مع تشديد الغرب لخناقه على قطاع الطاقه
الروسيه تتسارع استداره روسيا شرقا وتزداد
اهميه الصين كشريك طاقه اساسي لموسكو فا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلفاءه اطلقوا جوله من
العقوبات تحضر لاستيراد البحري للخام
الروسي الى اوروبا وتضعوا سقفا سعريا عليه
كشرط لاستخدام خدمات الشركات الاوروبيه في
التامين والشحن وما حضر اوروبا الاستراد
المشتقات النفطيه الروسيه في الخامس من
فبراير المقبل تتوقع اس ان في جلوبل ان
يطال ذلك نحو ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون
برميل يوميا من الخام الروسي ومشتقاته ومع
اشتداد العقوبات الغربيه تهدف روسيا الى
اعاده توجيه تلك الكميات من النفط والغاز
التي عاده ما كانت تتدفق الى اوروبا نحو
اسواق بديله ويتصدر الجار الحدودي الصيني
قائمه الخيارات المتاحه بح فقربه الجغرافي
وكونه اكبر مستورد ومستهلك للطاقه في
العالم وقد شهدت علاقات الطاقه الروسيه
الصينيه تطورا ملفتا في السنوات القليله
الاخيره في البيانات الروسيه الرسميه تشير
الى ازدياد حجم التبادل التجاري بين
البلدين في قطاع الطاقه منذ مطلع العام
الماضي وحتى نهايه اكتوبر ب 10%
وبحسب شركه رزناف الروسيه فان صادراتها
النفطيه الى الصين ارتفعت خلال نفس الفتره
بتسعه ونصف المئه مقارنه بنفس الفتره قبل
عام لتصل الى نحو مليون و700,000 برميل
يوميا في روسيا تصدر نفطها الى الصين من
خلال قناتين اما عبر خط انابيب اس او
والبالغ طوله نحو 4900 كلم بساعه 700,000
برميل يوميا واما عبر ناقلات النفط
البحريه التي من المتوقع يشهد نشاط
وهزديادا في العقد القادم عبر خط الملاحه
البحري الجديد المعروف باسم الممر البحري
الشمالي والذي يمر على طول ساحل القطب
الشمالي الروسي
والمتجه شرقا نحو المحيط الهادئ الاسيوي
حيث يتميز هذا الممر بفتره زمنيه اقصر
للوصول من القطب الشمالي الى المحيط
الهادئ مقارنه بالممرات التقليديه حيث
تعمل روسيا والصين بشكل المشترك على
تطويره هذا الممر البحري وسبب اهميه هذا
الخط الملاحي الجديد هو بدء روسيا مؤخرا
تطوير اكبر مشروع نفطي لها منذ انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي وذلك في شمال البلاد على
ساحل القطب الشمالي وهو مشروع بسطه والذي
سيبدا التصدير عام 20 24 لساعه 600,000
برميلا ليصل بحسب المستهدفات الى مليونين
300,000 برميل يوميا بحلول عام 20 33
وارتفاع الصادرات الروسيه الى الصين لا
يتوقف عند النفط فحسب ليشمل طبعا الغاز
الطبيعي فبحسب البيانات الروسيه الرسميه
ارتفعت الصادرات الروسيه من الغاز الموسال
الى الصين في الاشهر العشره الاولى من
العام الماضي ل 32% مقارنه بالعام الاسبق
روسيا ايضا تصدر الغاز الطبيعي الى الصين
عبر خط انابيب باور اوف سايبيريا والذي
بدا العمل عام 2019 وبلغ معدل وتدفق الغاز
فيه العام الماضي 41 مليون متر مكعب يوميا
ويامل المسؤولون الروس الى زياده هذا
المعدل الى 60 مليون متر مكعب يوميا العام
الجاري
علاقه الطاقه الروسيه الصينيه توطدت اكثر
خلال العقد الاخير مع توجه استثمارات
صينيه نحو مشاريع طاقه روسيه لا سيما بعد
عام 2014 الذي شهد عقوبات ماليه غربيه على
روسيا في ضوء ضمها لجزيره القرم ومن بين
ابرز الاستثمارات الصينيه في روسيا مشروع
جمال ال جي الذي تمتلك فيه شركه سي ان بي
سي حصه 20% اضافه الى مشروع ال جي والذي
تمتلك فيه سي ان في سي ايضا حصه 10% الى
جانب حصه مماثله لنظيرتها الصينيه سينوك
ولكن بالرغم من الجهود الروسيه في تعزيز
التعاون مع الصين في مجال الطاقه وتعهد
بكين بعدم تاثر علاقتها التجاريه مع روسيا
جراء العقوبات الغربيه الا ان هناك عده
تحديات تواجه ازدياد حجم صادرات روسيا من
النفط والغاز الى الصين اولها احتدام
المناف مع المصدرين الاخرين في السوق
الصينيه مثل منتجين الخليج وافريقيا وحتى
الولايات المتحده
ثانيا حدود قدرات التصدير الروسيه الى
الصين
ثالثا والربما اهمها مصلحه الصين
الاستراتيجيه في تنويع مصادرها من الطاقه
لتشمل منتجين اخرين ذو موثوقيه وعدم
الاعتماد بشكل اساسي على روسيا كمصدر وحيد
وللصين عبره في المانيا واعتمادها المفرط
على الغازات الروسي
[موسيقى]
اذا الالتفاف شرقا نحو طبعا الصين يبدو
انه الخيار الطبيعي لموسكو لتوفير سوق
بديله لانتاجها من النفط والغاز لكن ما
ابرز التحديات التي تواجه الخيار هذا
خصوصا في قطاع الغاز طرحت هذا السؤال على
روبن ميلز الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه قمر
بدي اكشن
16 12
الى ما عزمات الطاقه السابقه وهل بالامكان
ربطها بسلسله احداث تاريخيه وسياسات سابقه
ادت الى اعاده انتاج هذه الازمه بصورتها
الحاليه
الان افصل
بلاي ستيشن
بالرغم من ازمه الطاقه والعقوبات غير
المسبوقه الا ان الاضطرابات التي نتجت
عنها بقيت حتى الساعه على اقله محدودا
نوعا ما تفسير كوبن لذلك
بن تن
احد
الاوكرانيه والعقوبات المرتبطه بها هي
نهايه سوق النفط العالميه الحره ونشو سوق
نفطيه مقسمه وذات تدفقات تجاريه مجزئه هل
برايك روبن هذه هي نتيجه حتميه وكيف ترى
تطور الامور على هذا الصعيد
صور فيديو
بسم الله
»
ولكن ما هي توقعاتك للعام الحالي هل سيكون
افضل من العام 20 22 برايك
موقع
نتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع فاصل قصير نفتح
بعده ملف الانبعاثات في قطاع الاسمنت
القوم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه قطعوا
الاسمنت من اكثر القطاعات تسببا بانبعاثات
الغازات الدفيئه بعض التقديرات تشير الى
انه يساهم بنحو 7% من مجمل انبعاث ثاني
اكسيد الكربون ولذلك هناك ضغوط على هذا
القطاع بالذات لتنفيذ تحسينات تكنولوجيا
لخفض تلك الانبعاثات والدول المنطقتنا
نصيب من هذه الضغوط كونها تساهم بنسبه
كبيره ومعتبره من بعثات قطاع الاسمنت
عالميا حول هذا الملف كانت لنا مقابله
معيا رايلي الرئيس التنفيذي للمنظمه
العالميه للاسمنت وسؤالنا الاول له كان عن
خريطه الانبعاثات الناتجه عن قطاع الاسمنت
وما هي اكثر الدول تسببا بها لان نتابع
هذه المقابله التي اجرتها زميلتي سامر
المصري
طب ماشي
تصدرها صناعه الاسمنت مسؤوله عن نحو سبعه
في المئه من مجمل انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وبطبع يتم انتاجها حول العالم
والجزء الاكبر من هذه الانبعاث ياتي من
الصين والهند لكن منطقه الشرق الاوسط
تساهم بنحو 15 في المئه من انبعاثات صناعه
الاسمنت خارج
الصينيين التي يتم الاخذ بها اليوم لتقليل
هذه الانبعاثات
الاولى هي كفاءه الطاقه والثانيه التحول
في نوع الوقود والثالثه خفض نسبه الكلينكر
في الاسمنت الكريم هي الماده التي يتم
صنعها في المظهر وهناك يتم اصدار الجزء
الاكبر
كيلو رافعه كبيره لخفض بعثاه ثاني اكسيد
الكربون في الاسمنت شركات الاسمنت حول
العالم تعمل على هذه الرافعات منذ نحو 20
عاما وتمكنت في المتوسط من خفض الانبعاثات
بنحو 25% مقارنه بمستويات عام 1990 لكن
اذا نظرنا الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط كان
تخفيض الانبعاثات اقل بكثير وفي الحقيقه
ما زال معدل الانبعاثات لكل طن من الاسمنت
اقل بقليل من ما كان عليه قبل 20 او 30
عاما لذلك هناك كثير من الثمار السهله
القطاف والكثير من الفرص لشركات الصناعه
الاسمنت لخفضات كنسبه الى الطن وخفض
التكاليف في الوقت ذاته
توقعاتنا تشير الى وجود فرصه لخفض
الانبعاثات السنوات المقبله بقليل من
الاستثمارات ولخفضها بمقدار النصف
باستثمارات قليله نسبيا وذات عائدا جدا
اقتصاديه فعليا
عندما يستخدم الناس وهذا التعبير يقصدون
الاسمنت الذي يتسبب من بعثات اقل من
الاسمنت التقليدي الا ان شركات مختلفه في
مناطق مختلفه لديها مفاهيم متباينه لما
يعنيه الاسمنت الاخضر في الحقيقه لذلك فما
نحتاج الى فاله هو الخروج من هذا كله
والطريقه الطبيعيه
اا هناك اا حديث اليوم عن اعاده تدوير
الاسمنت هل هذه فعلا حقيقه يمكن الاخذ بها
وهل هذه ايضا مجديه اقتصاديه
رائعه نراها في كل مكان هنا
لكن في كل مكان عندما نحتاج الى التصنيع
او التوسع الحضري نحتاج الى المزيد
والمزيد من الاسلام لكن الاسمنت في جوانب
سلبيه
احدها تسببه بكميات كبيره
يتحول الى مواد اقل قيمه في الغالب مواد
للردمي بمواصفات معينه والتحدي في اعاده
التدوير هو ان الاسمنت المطحون ليس قويا
بما يكفي بل يتطلب المزيد من الاسمنت
لجعده متماسكا هناك تقنيات ما زالت في
بدايتها لمواجهتها المشاكل وقد بدانا نرى
تطبيق هذه التقنيه ما سيجعل اعاده تدوير
الاسمنت اسهل واعتقد ان هذا تطور مهم جدا
يساعدنا في بناء الاقتصاد الدائري لذلك
عندما نتحدث عن الاقتصاد الدائري لا
يمكننا ان نتجاهل مواد البناء التي يشكل
جزءا كبيرا من المواد المسؤوله عن
الانبعاثات لذلك من المهم جدا لنا ان نجد
طريقه لاعاده تدوير الاسمنت الى موده اخرى
للوصول الى الاقتصاد الدائري فهم عساكر
الصناعات المنتجه للك
ربون وفي اي نطاقات تحديدا وهل هذا مجدي
اقتصاديا ايضا
حين يتعلق الامر باحتجاز الكربون ليس عليك
ان تفكر بوجهه استخدامه سواء كان اعاده
استخدام الكربون او تخزينها من الواضح ان
من الافضل اعاده استخدام الكربون في شيء
مفيد بدلا من تخزينه في باطن الارض لكن
سوق الكربون في الوقت الحالي ما زال صغيرا
للغايه وهذا من القيود من حيث الكنز لكن
القيد الاكبر هو تكلفه عمليه احتجاز
الاسمنت هو الماده ذات كثافه الكربونيه
الاعلى من حيث نسبه الانبعاثات الى كل
دولار من الاراده ولذلك هناك حساسيه كبيره
بتكلفه فصل الكربون وهنا لا بد للحكومات
ان تلعب دورا في تسعير الكربون او توفير
الحوافذ لجعل مشاري الكربون واعاده
استخدامه وتخزينه مجديه اقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
في هذا مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من مستقبل الطاقه دائما تابعونا على تويتر
تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه كلكم ايضا
استماع لحلقاتنا على العربيه
كامله على موقعنا على الانترنت العربيه
دوت نت سلاش بروجرامز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]